on attend la presse le quatrième pouvoir
c'est parce qu'elle a trois autres le
pouvoir du président de la république
c'est le pouvoir exécutif
celui les deux assemblées c'est le
pouvoir législatif et le pouvoir
judiciaire en france la première
manifestation historique du quatrième
pouvoir
c'est ça c'est j'accuse le fameux
article pour l'aurore écrit par emile
zola enfin il a écrit l'article titre
j'accuse et clemenceau qu'il l'a fait en
fait au moment de l' affaire dreyfus
plus près de nous woodward et bernstein
les deux journalistes du washington post
ont quand même avec l' affaire du
watergate amené le président nixon a
démissionné et dernièrement en france
inutile de vous dire que les révélations
du monde sur la troisième équipe dans la
sphère greenpeace risque d'avoir des
conséquences que nous ne sommes pas ici
pour imaginer le quatrième pouvoir
c'est aussi le titre d'un film de serge
leroy avec nicole garcia et philippe
noiret
merci merci merci beaucoup
alors le quatrième pouvoir parlez nous
un peu de leur pouvoir oui mais c'est
effectivement le titre du du film de
leroy cela dit je pense que moi je ne
sais pas si nos amis aux journalistes
seraient d'accord je trouve que plutôt
qu'un quatrième pouvoir
je pense que la presse doit être un
contre-pouvoir plutôt qu'un quatrième
c'est à dire qu'il doit il doit marquer
les limites il doit dénoncer les abus de
pouvoir quel qu'il soit enfin bon ça
c'est l'expression est entré dans les
moeurs et ces types du film de leroy bon
qui traite un petit peu de ça qui traite
si vous voulez de deux journalistes qui
ont découvert que le gouvernement leur
avait menti enfin avait menti à la
presse et donc au pays au sujet d'un
événement à consonance de politique
internationale et ses deux journalistes
bonson entendent entre les mains une
preuve de ce mensonge et c'est le
l'histoire à la fois des rapports entre
ces deux journalistes puisque hier une
femme et un homme comme par hasard
et puis d'autre part
l'histoire des des rapports entre ces
deux journalistes et le pouvoir le
gouvernement qui essaye un petit peu de
leur mettre des bâtons dans les roues
chose qui est de bonne guerre je pense
voilà alors je dirais que l'adaptation
et les dialogues sont de françoise
giroud oui elle a connu de très près les
intrigues oui je pense que c'était la
personne la mieux placée en france
compte enfin mise à part son talent
d'auteur mais les mieux placés pour
pouvoir traiter des rapports entre le
pouvoir et la presse
alors maintenant nous allons jouer
oui nous allons proposer à nos chers
candidats des sujets ni et puis ils vont
répondre à des questions et puis vont
faire d une enfin c'est scoop à la une
fabien ben écoutez je vous suis